l'amour à la longue c'est une injonction
contradictoire c'est d'être à la fois on
est porté vers l'autre on l'aime de plus
en plus avec les années on est de plus
en plus attaché à lui et en même temps
on ne cesse dans les engueulades de
vouloir le mettre à mort par la parole
il y a une qui fait le bonsoir bonsoir
ça va alors Yann Quebec prix Goncourt
1985 avec les noces barbares adaptés au
cinéma par Marion Hansel ensuite 15
romans le charme noir disparu dans la
nuit la force d'aimer Boris après
l'amour et vous publiez aujourd'hui chez
Fayard moi et toi alors le titre c'est
sans doute à un clin d'oeil au bouquin
de Géraldine non
comme ça sur l'amour alors que vous
c'est plutôt consacré au cas où du
couple oui c'est dire bon je suis parti
de l'idée qu'au départ dans un couple
c'est toi toi mon tout toi mon roi
c'était à dire que vraiment toi c'est là
c'est c'est l'idéal c'est c'est
l'émerveillement et au fur et à mesure
que les années passent on constate que
le mois reprend du poil de la bête que
le mois a à vouloir à nouveau protéger
ses abattis et se met à considérer
l'autre comme un véritable adversaire
donc finalement qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que la question de ce livre c'est que
devient l'amour une fois que le couple
ne pense plus qu'à s'engueuler et en
même temps quoi de plus beau qu'une
magnifique dispute passionnelle qu'une
splendide engueulade il y a un peu dans
ton biographie d'ailleurs dans ce roman
j'espère parce que c'est c'est assez
alors je fais le pitch Michel est
amoureux de Julia mais incapable de
l'aimer elle elle fait monter évidemment
la pression en se focalisant sans
relâche sur une supposée maîtresse que
leur fille aurait vu un jour dans la
baignoire enfin on n'est pas tellement
sûr d'ailleurs vous dites pas vraiment
vous n'êtes pas vraiment si c'est arrivé
et alors comment ce jeu mortel
effectivement extrêmement sadique qu'il
consiste à se faire mal sans cesser de
se faire du bien parce qu'ils font quand
même l'amour entre eux oui oui si bien
entendu mais quand je disais qu'il y
avait de l'autobiographie je veux dire
par là que il m'est arrivé dans des
disputes que j'ai pu avoir au cours de
mon existence avec je sais pas avec des
compagnes de constater que la femme est
toujours juste lorsqu'elle s'engueule
avec l'homme qu'elle est magnifique
comme elle a une puissance oratoire
extraordinaire que pendant qu'on se fait
engueuler on a qu'une envie c'est de
prendre des notes et on se dit que les
écrivains ont beaucoup à apprendre de la
femme qui les engueule et même
d'ailleurs que qu'un écrivain qui ne vit
pas qu'il a pas la chance de vivre avec
une femme colérique ne peut pas écrire
de bons livres sur la question c'est
mais en même temps c'est vrai que c'est
vrai qu'il sait mais ce sont des gens
qui se rapportent 43 vous écrivez en
ménage ils étaient deux
bernard-l'hermite incapable de
s'éloigner longtemps du lieu où il
reçoivent coût et vexation il s'est
disputé violemment mais se réconcilier à
la vie à la mort et chaque fois il se
met un peu plus cette espèce de comme ça
de ah ouais c'est la patience
c'est bien avec Moundir c'est
extraordinaire
j'adorais et alors je cherche des
disputes on discutait puis après on se
réconcilie bien après
c'est vrai que l'amour à la longue c'est
une injonction contradictoire
c'est-à-dire à la fois on est porté vers
l'autre on l'aime de plus en plus avec
les années on est de plus en plus
attaché à lui et en même temps on ne
cesse dans les engueulades de vouloir le
mettre à mort par la parole c'est une
espèce de c'est vrai cette phrase de
Guitry qu'on a déjà cité ici c'est
l'amour c'est ne plus faire qu'un seul
reste à savoir lequel
alors
il y a cette prétendue maîtresse femme
aux cheveux rouges à genoux dans la
baignoire donc qui a été vu par cette
gamine qui s'appelle pas pareil
d'ailleurs l'un et l'autre hein
essaie de gamine il y a des problèmes
psychologiques alors quand la mère dit
mais elle a vu la maîtresse dans dans la
baignoire on lui dit mais votre fille a
des problèmes et la mergueule elle dit
ne prenez pas ma fille pour une
illuminée donc on sait jamais vraiment
ce qui s'est passé on constate que
lorsqu'un couple sème tellement
d'ailleurs qu'il s'engue toute la
journée c'est forcément au détriment
d'un enfant qui se sont coupables dans
la dans la mauvaise du mauvais état
comme ça de la relation entre ses
parents et cette gamine mine de rien
elle est en train de se barrer
complètement alors cette gamine elle se
drogue elle va en maison de redressement
et d'ailleurs pendant tout le bouquin on
attend qu'elle revienne ils attendent
qu'elle revienne pour partir en voyage
sur un voilier à Toulon sur la
Méditerranée et là il y a une phrase
terrible
qui sait par quel aveuglement ce couple
se croyait sous le signe du grand amour
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait vous avez raison
c'est très juste que vous dites que tous
les couples même ceux qui se disputent
toute la journée se croisaient sous le
signe du grand amour
que reste-t-il de ce grand amour
et en même temps ce que j'ai aimé en
écrivant ce livre justement c'est la
Transfiguration romanesque comme ce
qu'il m'a qu'il m'a permis de faire
c'est-à-dire l'envie de faire entendre
lecteur non pas comme ça une scène de
ménage vulgaire celle qu'on entend à
travers les cloisons-trondins d'une
chambre d'hôtel mais vraiment quelque
chose d'universel c'est-à-dire que quand
on a l'impression le lisant que c'est
une résonance personnelle qu'on trouve
alors ils font l'amour mais c'est
terrible parce que lui à un moment il
pense que elle utilise son membre comme
un vulgaire vibro sortie du tiroir de la
commode et un peu après elle lui demande
comment était sa mère et là c'est
terrible
elle répond douce et molles comme ta
vieille queue c'est-à-dire effectivement
c'est que devient le désir à La Londe on
continue d'avoir des rapports sexuels
apparemment ça fonctionne très bien
parce qu'on se connaît très bien mais
cette espèce de trouble infiniment
mystérieux du premier désir il est en
voie de disparition il est souvent en
voie de disparité
non mais c'est terrible
c'est d'une crudité c'est d'une cruauté
absolument totale mais aussi d'une aussi
d'une tendresse et je ne dis pas ça pour
pour compenser la cruauté mais on voit
bien à la fin lorsque lorsqu'il est en
train justement de fuir devant sa femme
il repense à elle et il l'aime comme il
ne l'a jamais aimé au moment où il
risque vraiment de la perdre pour de bon
vous pensez que tous les tous les amours
sont condamnés à ce destin non je ne
crois pas mais ce qui est non je ne
crois pas il y a forcément des
exceptions mais lorsqu'on écrit un roman
on écrit si finalement pour essayer
d'embrasser la situation la plus
générique possible je crois que c'est un
de meilleur bouquins là
j'ai pris le plus grand plaisir à écrire
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
inarritube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu